what is vran or virtual radio access
network
how does it compare to traditional ran
hi i'm dan keen from ibm cloud
and before i answer those questions
please click like and subscribe
the short answer is vran is network
functionality delivered as software
instead of hardware
communication service providers are
already investing in 5g
so the timing is good to be able to
think about other ways they can make
their networks more flexible
that's where virtual radio access
networks which follow the open ran
architecture can help
to better understand vran it helps to
compare them side by side
vran versus traditional ram
so we've all seen a traditional site of
a cell tower up there as an antenna
along with the antenna is a remote radio
unit or
ru for short down on the ground
there's a different device called a base
span unit or bbu
the bbu takes the signals from the ru
and then forwards it on to the next
place in the chain
the central unit the central unit is
connected to multiple bbus within a
small region
and concentrates them to forward it on
to the core network
so for vran the picture starts out
basically the same
we have a tower antenna and ru
but what's different is instead of the
bbu we have a different device
called a vdu or virtual distribution
unit
it then connects to a different piece of
equipment
called a vcu or virtual central unit
which connects then to the core network
just as before
so on the surface these look pretty much
the same but there are some key
differences
the bbu is a fixed piece of hardware
proprietary with fixed capacity
on the other hand the vdu and vcu it
runs
on commercial off the shelf hardware and
then installed on that is software
called
a vnf or virtual network function
that provides the same functionality as
the bbu
but using software on commercial
off-the-shelf hardware
so now with that quick overview let's
look at three different scenarios to see
how they differ
the first one i call road trip
so let's imagine that you're driving
down the highway you're listening to
music
on your favorite streaming service that
signal is coming from this cell tower
and unfortunately you run across a
traffic jam
now you and the other driver is going to
want to think about ways you perhaps
avoid this traffic jam
so you bring up your navigation app you
might even call your family and say
you're going to be late resulting in
lots of different signals hitting the
same tower
potentially overwhelming this bbu
the scenario plays out a little bit
differently in the case of vran
now i showed just one vdu in the initial
drawing
but more realistically a csp would
install
multiple edu's in what's called a vdu
cluster
so that means they can handle the
situation much more elegantly because
they can bring on
additional capacity on demand
so let's look now at another scenario
which is not quite so
unpredictable this road trip i call
downtown
so we have a cluster of buildings
and with that cluster of buildings we
have lots of people
because there's lots of people we can
make predictions about what their usage
patterns might be
and so that means we'll be able to plan
essentially or automate
what capacity we need at what times for
example if we have office workers that
come in the morning
take lunch and then leave in the evening
we might see rises in demand
at those specific times but in the
evening we may only need
minimal capacity and thus we can apply
the level
of capacity that's required given the
demand
okay there's one final scenario that i
would like to cover
one that doesn't involve monitoring the
dynamic nature of the network
i call this one campus
so we've left the highway we're no
longer downtown we're on campus
and on this campus
they have a cell tower it's serving 5g
the dean of this campus wants to provide
wi-fi capability throughout the campus
not just in the buildings but anywhere
outside
so they can have outdoor classrooms for
example
so the csp can make an offer to them
they suggest that they
install a wi-fi capable antenna on the
existing tower
and because the vdu is software based
that means they can install
new services in this case
a wi-fi capable vnf
that wi-fi capability can be brought up
during the day while students are there
and be used
actively and in the evening where the
demand drops off
they can also reduce the capacity that
it provides therefore
offering a lot more flexibility
in how they deliver services
and here we offered a lot more dynamic
way of addressing our capacity demands
together these two really paint a
picture of
automation now automation or network
automation is really a separate topic in
and of itself and deserves its own video
so please look below in the description
for links about it
thank you for watching if you have
questions please drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like and subscribe